natale del 2009 sarà un periodo che
difficilmente riuscirò a dimenticare mi
ero imbattuto pochi mesi prima in un
articolo giornalistico su un settimanale
che parlava di mais geneticamente
modificato i cosiddetti ogm e l'articolo
era assolutamente categorico ci spiegava
che quel mais nuoce alla salute umana e
già nelle nostre bistecche e può causare
gravissime allergie sorpreso di queste
affermazioni così categoriche scrivo al
direttore del giornale gli domando se
esista un documento scientifico alla
base di affermazioni tanto categorica e
nasce un dibattito acceso dopodiché
aspetto la settimana successiva non c'è
nessuna smentita sul settimanale e
quindi ricostruisco l'intera vicenda sul
mio blog affermando due cose che non c'è
nessun dato scientifico alla base
all'articolo giornalistico e che
l'esperto intervistato nell'articolo non
ha mai parlato con il giornalista autore
del pezzo così a natale del 2009
ricevo una denuncia penale per
diffamazione
ora se a denunciarvi e la compagnia di
san paolo che assume per l'occasione gli
avvocati del corriere della sera
se la richiesta finanziaria di
indennizzo e 400 mila euro
se a denunciarvi è un giornale da mezzo
milione di copie che si chiama famiglia
cristiana capirete perché è difficile
passare delle serene festività natalizie
ora
questa storia andrà avanti ancora per
quattro anni finché una giudice non
sentenzierà che io ero risalito alle
fonte originale di conoscenza e che era
scritto il falso nell'articolo
giornalistico di famiglia cristiana
contentezza per una vicenda giudiziaria
finita bene no tristezza tristezza di
essere stato incapace di parlare a
famiglia cristiana di scambiarci
opinioni documenti tristezza di aver
lasciato i lettori nello sconcerto
soprattutto di non aver di aver visto
tanta fiducia in un prestigioso
settimanale su un innovazione
scientifica ma soprattutto è un caso
eccezionale di distanza fra scienza e
società civile o succede spesso
io temo che succede piuttosto spesso di
bufale scientifiche le vediamo in
continuazione a partire da quella dei
vaccini e correlati all'autismo un guaio
che mette in grande difficoltà l'intero
l'intero paese ma come non di non
ricordare la vicenda del professor di
bella la sua cura per il cancro che ha
paralizzato la ricerca oncologica in
questo paese per un anno intero
ponendolo sfiducia nelle canio terapie
bruno vespa ha scritto un libro con il
professor di bella e tanti politici sono
saltati su quel carro come dimenticare
la recente vicenda della professoressa
ilaria capua linciata sulla stampa
nazionale poi incolpata di i reati così
gravi che prevedevano anche l'ergastolo
poi riabilitata fuggita all'estero
dimessasi dal parlamento senza che
nessuno le chiedesse scusa e come
scordarsi non so della vicenda del della
sentenza in primo grado per tutta la
commissione grandi rischi
quella del terremoto dell'aquila sei
anni
l'esclusione a tutta la commissione per
non aver allertato la popolazione sulla
possibilità di un rischio di un
terremoto e le mie senti possano andare
avanti quanto volete natale dell'anno
scorso la procura della repubblica di
lecce mette sotto indagine cinque
scienziate cinque amministratori
gli scienziati sono colpevole aver
trovato la realtà cioè che c'è un
batterio silella fastidiosa nel salento
responsabile della moria degli ulivi gli
amministratori sono responsabili di aver
attuato o voler attuare le procedure in
caso di emergenza per un'epidemia come
questa si lella e un patogeno da
quarantena
ma la procura della repubblica di lecce
ci vede dei sordi di giochi di
multinazionali che vogliono spargere
erbicidi nota che la multinazionale
monsanto sette anni prima ha acquistato
un'altra azienda biotecnologica di nome
alle leaks ora lele per uno genetista è
un termine corrente due geni che vengono
da due organismi diversi ea svolgono la
stessa funzione
ma la procura si vede una cosa diversa
scrive che alle leaks e la palindrome
dixie lella
la palindrome cioè la settimana
enigmistica può servire per svelare i
sordi di intrighi delle multinazionali
a questo siamo ridotti in questo paese
ma soprattutto il problema è come fa un
singolo magistrato a discernere tra
esperti e autori autorevoli a livello
internazionale e ciarlatani come fa da
solo a capire chi è la persona a cui
affidarsi guardate io ho lavorato tanti
anni al pasteur a parigi il direttore
del pasteur è sempre stato un consulente
del primo ministro francese per non
parlare di quello che succede alla
ragazzo site che scrivi in continuazione
documenti tecnici che fanno da base per
le scelte poi dei politici come
dimenticare che il presidente obama va
alla national academy of science negli
stati uniti a parlare della visione che
lui a della ricerca scientifica
quando mai abbiamo sentito un nostro
politico parlarci della sua visione
della ricerca scientifica e pure saremo
la patria di galileo della ii lei del
metodo scientifico ma noi non ci
crediamo più nel metodo scientifico
guardate si è parlato stamattina piero
angela ci parlava della divulgazione
scientifica l'italia ha una legge per la
diffusione della cultura scientifica
i fondi a quella legge l'anno scorso
sono stati tagliati del 40 per cento e
prima ancora di questo taglio i grandi
musei italiani quelli che fanno
divulgazione scientifica aveva un budget
dieci volte inferiore dei loro
corrispondenti francesi tedeschi e
inglesi
questa è la situazione nella quale
stiamo mettendo e questa è quello che ci
stiamo giocando noi ci stiamo giocando i
20 anni prossimi di possibilità di far
crescere una nuova generazione di di
persone competenti di scienza diceva
valerio albertini stamattina che ci
evolviamo perché finalmente vengono
rimossi quelle della mia generazione e
arrivano i nuovi
noi ci stiamo giocando i nuovi rimaniamo
noi vi rendete conto è il problema
questa è la ragione per cui poi fuggono
all'estero fuggono in tutte le categorie
all'estero
sono solo gli scienziati perché quando
un paese declina declina in tutte le sue
classe furono tutti per non tornare mai
più
guardate che non fuggono solo gli
scienziati fuggono i pizzaioli e gli
operai specializzati e la il rapporto di
migrantes che appena spiegato che adesso
stanno fuggendo principalmente a
lombardia e veneto dalle regioni ricche
stanno fuggendo
questo è quello che ci stiamo giocando
per il nostro futuro
scappano tutti quanti va bene
voi direte ma di bella
la professoressa ilaria capua i vaccini
gli ogm
la commissione grandi rischi o gli ulivi
del salento cosa c'entrano l'uno con
l'altro se lo chiedete uno scienziato vi
dirà è colpa dei media che non fanno
scrivere colpa dei magistrati che fanno
questo e quell'altro
in tutti i casi è colpa della politica
va bene si tutto vero ma se io posso
dirvi una cosa io vi direi un'altra cosa
se tutto questo è potuto accadere in
questo paese e soprattutto colpa degli
scienziati è colpa degli scienziati che
non hanno imposto la loro visione è
colpa degli scienziati che in una parte
di alcuni scienziati ma troppi in questo
paese hanno pensato alla loro carriera
al loro interesse personale o andare e
limo simhara elemosinare finanziamenti
individuali che sono sempre state pure
elemosina questo è quello che è successo
in questo paese
se tutto questo è successo e perché
l'italia non ha una sola voce la scienza
non ha una sola voce per parlare serve
un gruppo ristretto un coordinamento un
gruppo identificabile di persone poi
estremamente ramificato capace di
entrare in tutte le discipline del
sapere a redigere documenti a fornire
opinioni soprattutto a fornire
rappresentanti della comunità
scientifica ai media i magistrati alla
politica non persone cooptate dalla
politica per annuire alle loro decisioni
già prese
questa è la cosa che deve cambiare
gli scienziati devono identificare chi
sono gli esperti autorevoli campo per
campo disciplina per disciplina tematica
per tematica e devono riuscire a fare
con tutti gli altri attori e se questi
non vogliono sentire quello che dice la
scienza devono essere in grado di
saltare le mediazioni e arrivare
direttamente al pubblico come succede in
gran bretagna con sense about science
cioè organizzazioni che mettono
direttamente in contatto scienziati e
pubblico uno scienziato però che si deve
spiegare aprire parlare in termini
comprensibili raccontare i fatti
accogliere le ansie le paure le opinioni
avere il tempo di farlo e agire con i
tempi dei media che non sono i tempi
dell'accademia dei mesi di riunioni sono
i tempi immediati le reazioni devono
essere all'istante non è possibile
pensare che si reagisce alcune settimane
dopo di fronte a un'emergenza di
qualunque genere
ecco questo è quello che è mancato è
mancato un coordinamento è mancata un
identità è mancata un gruppo di
coordinamento capace di di essere
riconoscibile come gli scienziati di
questo paese capaci di redigere i
documenti di fare affermazioni di
entrare in tutte le discipline capaci
di fare quello che ci diceva dall'essere
albertini stamattina noi se non
riusciamo a proporre una nuova visione
della scienza non recupereremo nessuno
delle centinaia delle migliaia di
ragazze che abbiamo espulso che abbiamo
mandato all'estero senza più nessuna
speranza di farli tornare perché non c'è
meritocrazia non c'è logica non c'è
nulla di tutto questo lo abbiamo sentito
in tutti questi giorni da raffaele
cantone con le parentopoli
dell'università fino in giù
allora o cambia profondamente questo
sistema o noi non riusciremo a far
tornare tutti questi ragazzi e solo loro
ci possano aiutare per tracciare una
rotta nuova rotta per questo paese un po
più civile un po più democratico grazie